in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Andrew
and Amanda are with us hey guys how are
you but I deserve Dave I loved it I
loved it were y'all from sweetest place
on earth Hershey Pennsylvania
butter boom I love it very cool now it
was that your sister that was all a
little bit earlier Amanda that's your
sister because I know we've got three
siblings in the three hours doing their
debt free scream so it was your sister
that lives in China yes that was here to
do her debt free scream and now you guys
are here that's correct
awesome how much have you paid off we
paid off 67,000 in 25 months way to go
making what kind of money during that
time we started at about 80,000 and we
finished about ninety three thousand why
did he go what do y'all do for a living
we worked it together actually at a
private boarding school Oh Nate very fun
teaching runs in your family then yes
apparently okay very good and what kind
of debt was a sixty seven thousand uh
we're we're super normal people so we
had our student loans had our car loans
and had a little bit of credit card debt
all right yeah so what happened 25
months ago well my sister that was on
last hour was working on hers and we
just got to a point where we had a bump
in income that we could start to get
more aggressive on our debt we always
wanted to be debt-free it was about that
time we got your book to the Total Money
Makeover I think I was just the right
thing at the right time you know and we
went to Lancaster Bible College and at
college they did budgeting eye classes
but I still remember this couple coming
in and they this huge binder and then
they had us look at this excel sheet
that was like 25 pages it was just
overwhelming and so I guess we just
never budgeting class was don't do this
it's painful yes we always wanted to be
debt-free but we just didn't really have
a plan or a way to execute it so we kind
of didn't really have just paid minimums
on our student loans and went out and
got a car loan because that's what
people do and you know you know kind of
just as you say we wandered into debt
and we kind of floundered there for a
while and so how long have you guys been
married we've been married almost nine
years okay so seven years in the
marriage your sister's getting out of
that the Total Money Makeover book shows
up and you got a bump in income and
that's reason enough to get started on
this you okay let's do this
but what caused you to get intense um we
really just I mean that was right we
started that snowball right after our
youngest daughter was born ah now we're
gone okay we just and there are our
daughters are here with us today and we
didn't want to keep in that situation
because we which is really hitting us
that the borrower is slave to the lender
and we just felt trapped we felt the
weight of the debt that we couldn't move
forward with some of the things we want
to do and we love to travel we love
being overseas go to China to visit my
sister friend to live in Taiwan we've
gone to be visit them there's something
about a baby that makes you look into
the future yes and go wait a minute yeah
this isn't working we have to change
something so she was born and that was
right about the time were like you know
what we we can be debt-free before 30 so
we said we got two years we just let's
knock it out so we just really got our
snowball rolling I'm a geek I had the
spreadsheet not 25 pages not 20 it was
one page I was big it was on the fridge
at the beginning we were embarrassed
about it when we had people over we'd
hide it but as we crossed stuff off we'd
leave it up there because it was you
know we're getting this done yeah
and so we we got I also have a couple of
friends from our church we're trying to
do the same thing around the same time
so there's actually been two or three
couples that are friends of ours either
aren't really close or have paid off all
their dozen last year too neat so you
had some good positive peer pressure
around you with family and then those
couples as well very cool very cool so
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of that is you did it in 25
months there are a lot of times we
wanted to give up you know he's like you
know we could go spend money and life
would be easier right now but that's
what got us into our situation so it's
really an even now contentment just you
know we're happy with what we have or
our family is healthy or how our family
is safe and we don't need all those
things that you know we go into debt for
so it's just really I think having that
goal to like having the budget and
having a we like I think that just
really helped us that when we had that
vision and that goal that we wanted to
then was kind of fun to cross the things
off and get to that goal sense of sense
of traction really does make a big
difference I think that's why the debt
snowball work so well when you knock off
that little one it gives you that sense
of I can do this yes I can do this I can
really do this what was the hardest part
for you guys probably the hardest part
was getting started because we're
pushing that snowball uphill and you
know we knocked off the first couple
student loans and kept pushing and
finally you know about a year into it we
got to the top of the hill and that
snowball really started rolling and then
that last year of our of our journey we
knocked it out and it was totally worth
it yeah very cool well congratulations
you two very very well done it's a
family affair today each of the three
hours are three siblings and your two
daughters are joining us how old are
they and what are their names
this is this is Kennedy she's four and
this is Ellie she is - all right Kennedy
and Ellie are gonna join us
have they been practicing their debt
free scream they have this yes all right
very good all right Andrew and Amanda
from Hershey Pennsylvania $67,000 paid
off in 25 months making 80 up to 93 a
year count it down let's hear a debt
free scream three two one
absolutely did it man that's awesome
very cool very very well done I love it
neat thing they are the three siblings
decided to wait until their sister was
home from China to do their debt free
screams together and so we were able to
arrange him on a day when I was here to
get them all three down her at the same
time so one each hour of the three hours
of the show today very fun stuff
congratulations you guys very proud of
you awesome job hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show and so you have to
break the cycle you have to flip this
thing on its head and make it behave
you've got to get so fired up and wired
up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind